the nhs is doing an absolutely
extraordinary job a heroic job in very
very difficult circumstances and so the
the most important thing we can do right
now
as a government is continue to to
support to increase the support we're
giving to all our hospitals or all our
nhs staff making sure that we have uh
more of the the nurses the doctors that
they need that's why we've invested
massively through the uh the health
social care levy uh that's very very
important for the nhs and to to clear
these backgrounds enable them uh to deal
with copid uh right now and uh to catch
up
uh but what we've also got to do is make
sure that people understand
the pressures
that
omicron is causing and
the way to to deal with it is for
everybody to to stick to plan b which we
are make sure that they
behave sensibly but also recognize the
vital importance of a vaccination
and when you look at what's happening to
patients coming into hospital a large
number of them perhaps 30 40 percent of
them haven't actually been vaccinated at
all and that's
increasingly true of people who go into
to icu into intensive care
the the large majority of them have not
been vaccinated at all and the
overwhelming majority of them have not
been boosted and so i at this stage and
i haven't said this before
uh in this whole uh vaccination campaign
i just want to to reach out to all those
who
have not been
yet vaccinated and say it's a great
thing but i also want to say uh to the
anti-vaxx campaigners uh the people who
are putting this uh this mumbo-jumbo
on social media
they are completely wrong and you
haven't heard me say that before because
i think it's important that we uh you
know where we make i want a voluntary
approach in this country and we're going
to keep a voluntary approach i believe
in
doing things through
everybody working together and seeing
the vital importance of
vaccination and we've got much higher
rates of vaccination in this country
thanks to that
community-led voluntary approach that's
a wonderful thing other european
countries are going for coercion
but
what a tragedy
that we've got all this pressure on the
nhs all the difficulties that
our doctors and nurses are experiencing
and you've got people out there spouting
complete nonsense
about a vaccination
that they are totally wrong
and i think it it's time that
i government call them out on what
they're doing it is absolutely wrong
it's totally counterproductive and the
stuff they're putting out on social
media is complete mumbo jumbo
we do have all this pressure on the nhs
as you've described we're hearing
reports daily now of nurses working
13-hour shifts without breaks staff
crying at the thought of another
impossible shift or being signed off
with stress you've said the nhs is on a
war footing but you've sent them to
fight without the staff they need to be
able to do that
well that's not true because uh i mean
well first of all uh the
yes i i appreciate that the nhs is under
huge pressure and
uh yes i you're quite right romney what
you say about
uh the the way it's been
continuous over the last 18 months we've
had wave after wave of of covid and our
nhs has responded magnificently and and
they they've kept going and of course i
understand how
frustrating it is to to see another wave
coming in and i i i thank doctors nurses
all health staff uh everybody for what
they're doing uh to keep going
um
what we are doing
is increasing the support massively so
there are 5 000 more doctors
this year than there were this time last
year
10 000 more nurses and
and we're recruiting and we're we're
recruiting many many we're recruiting
many many more
and what we're also doing is making sure
we call back to the colours uh retired
medical staff uh we've got the army of
volunteers uh moving into to help with
the with the crisis and of course
we will get through this this wave of
omicron uh is putting huge pressure on
the nhs
the the difference is of course that it
is uh it is milder uh but
the pressures on uh on hospitals are
clear that what we've got to do is give
the nhs all the help we can through the
next period
with all the
simplifications of systems moving staff
from one hospital to another all the
ways we can back staff up but also make
sure that the people who are likely to
get ill
get vaccinated first and
you know i
the saddest words in the english
language are too late
too late you know when you when you're
in icu
and you haven't been vaccinated i'm i i
sadly it's too late to get vaccinated so
get boosted now
um lord geith's letters are going to be
published soon do you really expect the
public to believe you didn't disclose
key messages with lord brownlow about
the refurbishment of your flat because
you had a new phone i followed the
ministerial guidance at all times and
and yes
surely you'd remember such an exchange
even if you couldn't see the messages i
followed the ministerial guidance at all
times
okay can i just two quick questions are
you concerned about the ruling in the
colston case
look i don't want to to comment on that
particular
uh judgment uh
and it's it's a
um a matter for the court but what i
what i would say is that um
my feeling is
that we have a
complex
historical legacy all around us
and it reflects our
history in all its diversity for for
good or ill
what you can't do is go around seeking
retrospectively to change our our
history or to to boundarize it or edit
it in retrospect uh you know it's like
some
you know uh
person trying to edit their wikipedia
entry uh it's it's it's wrong and i
think we should if people democratically
i want to
remove a statue or whatever that's fine
uh but i think that in in general we
should preserve
uh
our cultural artistic historical legacy
that's my view and and finally you had a
powerful message to the unvaccinated
today do you think the australians are
right to take a tough stance with novak
djokovic
it's a matter for
uh for australia and uh they're they're
friendly uh government and uh have the
utmost respect for the australian
government i think that's a that's a
matter for them but clearly i share very
strongly the view of
the australian authorities it's a very
good idea to get vaccinated